the new Apple TV starts with a powerful  set-top box in a revolutionary remote  it's got an incredible new user  interface it's built on a modern OS with  an iPhone you interact directly on the  screen and we wanted to bring the same  connected experience to your television  even though it's across the room and to  do that it starts with voice and with  touch the new remote sorry the new  remote has a glass touch surface across  the top that makes it both fluid and  precise to move around we have a great  touch experience and you can easily  glide across a set of movies and when  you see one you like you just stop and  it's right there